Books,
Tim Ferriss here,
author of the four hour workweek,
tools of titans,
et cetera.
You might imagine that all my days are good days.
I wake up and I conquer anxiety and doubt,
lack of clarity with a mental karate chop and I just annihilate the day hitting
home runs,
every single pitch that's thrown my way.
That's not really how it works.
Usually I wake up,
I'm a little groggy,
maybe I got bad sleep,
had too much wine,
who knows and stumbled through my day.
Uh,
occasionally I have a good day and that is quite frankly enough for me.
And let me explain some of the questions I ask.
Some of the coping mechanisms I use when the day gets off on the wrong foot for
whatever reason.
Maybe I find myself at lunch or after lunch feeling like I haven't accomplished
anything.
What do I do in such cases?
Well the first is really a question that I use many,
many,
many times throughout a given say week or month.
And that is which of these from looking at my to do list,
much of which is probably undone in a case like this.
Which one of these if accomplished,
would make everything else easier or irrelevant?
I'll say it again.
Which one of these if checked off would make everything else easier or
irrelevant meaning less important or completely unimportant.
All right.
The other question that you can use which is more or less the same is which of
these if checked off would leave me satisfied with my day?
Right?
Which one of these third question and eventually you will fall,
come up with an answer that is actionable is which of these if done creates more
time for me next week and it could be next month,
it could be tomorrow,
but next week I find to be useful as a timeline and this will generally point to
some type of process or system that you can improve.
So okay,
maybe you're not going to hit a certain milestone or ship a certain article or
something as a finished work product,
but you can improve a system or a process.
We'll actually probably have it higher ROI over time and effect many,
many other individual projects.
Okay,
so a which one of these,
if if accomplished,
would make everything else easier or element number two,
which one of these would leave me satisfied with my entire day?
If it was the only thing I accomplished on this list today and then the last,
which one of these will create more time for me next week or more time for other
people for that matter.
And then,
uh,
I would also say that you don't have to be super,
super productive every day and maybe if you're in some type of zero sum game,
you've chosen to be a venture backed startup where everyone arsons everyone,
but you have three or four nearly identical companies,
all Kline for market share and it's some type of network effect based business.
Who knows in such a case,
okay,
maybe you've signed up for the full contact sport.
That is the venture back startup world.
Too bad you have ADR or weeks from here until it either succeeds or it blows to
pieces in a Supernova of capital destruction.
Aside from that,
if you are,
say a writer,
uh,
a an entrepreneur,
even CEO,
I know plenty of CEOS are certainly fall in this category,
you're not going to be super productive and on point every day and that's okay.
So it's not as though you have to have a minimum number of hours each day within
which you are hyper productive.
In fact,
I know a lot of people who will go through periods of being very,
very unproductive for say a handful of days,
maybe handful of weeks if they're on a deadline and just stuck in a Rut as it
relates to say,
music writing or anything else.
You don't have to get a lot of things right if you pick the right thing.
So this comes back,
and I'm not going to Belabor the point,
but read the effective executive by Peter Drucker.
What you do matters a lot more than how much you do or how well you do things.
If you pick the right targets,
you can get a very,
very high ROI because you have an Archimedes lever.
What does that mean?
Archimedes lever means in particular context that you're choosing?
Say projects and goals that have beneficial side effects even if they don't turn
out as planned.
So you're choosing say,
and this is very much borrowed from Scott Adams who created Dilbert,
which projects and so on,
can I commit myself to through which I will develop some skills and
relationships that persist even if they fail from the outside world.
And so if I do a podcast and I commit to six episodes,
even if that podcast goes nowhere,
which is how I thought about it,
which skills and relationships can I develop in the process of doing six
episodes that will make the exercise worth it?
All right,
and that will transcend to that.
That's also one of the tricks and if you find yourself saying by mid afternoon
feeling really unproductive,
you done nothing productive for the day,
you can't quite figure out how to work your way out of it.
What I've found myself doing a as perhaps just a self imposed therapy is saying,
okay,
maybe today isn't achievement day today is just going to be gratitude and
appreciation day.
So let me go for a walk.
Let me notice the small things.
Let me do a nice thing for someone in line and buy coffee for the person behind
me at Starbucks,
whatever it might be,
and focus on the other side of the coin,
which I think is equally important for contentment in any forum of wellbeing or
happiness.
And that is appreciating what you have.
So if you can't get what you want,
you can practice wanting what you have and as fortune cookie is,
that may sound,
I think that if you can't be happy with what you have,
you will never get anything that will make you happy.
So you have to practice both achievement and if you're flubbing that for the day
or just like with with okay air ball and you're just not making it happen,
okay,
maybe that is a sign from the universe or whatever power you want to choose that
you can take the day and focus on gratitude because that has a much less of a
stress associated with it in terms of pass fail,
that is something you can always make the most of,
even if you only have a few hours left in the day.
So those are a few of the things that I do when the day gets off on the wrong
foot,
or I feel like I am getting absolutely fuck all done with my day.
So hopefully that helps.
Good luck.
Thanks for watching the video.
I have more tips and tactics and actionable stuff to share.
Every week I send out an exclusive newsletter called five bullet Friday.
It's totally free.
It takes about five minutes to read.
It includes what I'm reading,
what type of tips I've received from world class experts,
weird gadgets and Gizmos that I found from,
say Japan or God knows where all sorts of really,
really esoteric but valuable stuff that you probably wouldn't find yourself.
So check it out.
Five bullet Friday right here.